hey guys it's justine and today apple
announced
the top 15 best apps of 2020.
this includes iphone ipad tv apple watch
and mac i also got a chance to chat with
some of the developers of some of these
apps
it was kind of cool to hear their
perspective some of them have been
creating these apps
for a very very long time for example
one of the winners for the app trend of
the year
is explain everything it's kind of this
real-time
whiteboarding app that has been used in
a lot of different classrooms now this
company has been working on this
app for almost 10 years and it was
really incredible to hear from them
directly how much work they put into
this
and how now at a time when this is
something that is needed more than ever
it's something that could not have been
duplicated in such a short amount of
time to kind of fill that need
for this app so every year there's kind
of a trend with apps and
this year the trend was helpfulness
which kind of is
very fitting we've been using apps to do
so many different things now i mean i
feel like we're actually relying on them
more than ever obviously this year has
changed the way that we do so many
things
from just everyday tasks like working
out
to working working to connecting with
our friends and family because we can't
do
in-person gatherings anymore these are
kind of the apps that have been helpful
in getting things done
and making our lives a little bit more
manageable
for this 2020. so first up let's go
through the best
of the 20 20 winners number one the
iphone
app of the year is wake out i did get a
chance to chat with the developers of
this one they basically started it as an
app
that you open up every day when you wake
up and then you do some exercises
but what this app has turned into during
this whole pandemic
craziness is quite fascinating during
the quarantine it became
something more special than that we were
looking for and we we've been able to
help
families uh just stay active we'd like
to invite you
to do just a very brief 30s okay wake up
do i have to stand up
tell us where you are from okay good i'm
attached
[Music]
it's a great concept because i think a
lot of people don't realize how much you
can actually do just with body weight
and they're like no i have to go to a
gym i have to go to this like no you
have yourself like you're fine
it's about getting that like spark of
energy basically just getting started
and just being able to just be silly
anywhere
number two is the iphone game of the
year engine impact
number three the ipad app of the year is
zoom have you guys heard of a zoom have
you used it before have we
we've all used it we all know what it is
the ipad game of the year is legends of
runeterra
and this is actually by riot so i'm sure
many of you have played league of
legends or at least heard of league of
legends i actually played league of
legends when it first came out and then
over the years i went to tons of their
esports tournaments and league of
legends is such a fun game so this is
kind of
bringing a lot of those champions from
league of legends into
this card based game i've never played
this game before and now after
hearing more about it guess what i did i
downloaded it i'm jeff joo
i'm the executive producer for legends
of roonterra and league of legends has
been one of the world's most played
games for over 10 years
we wanted a game that changed the way
that players thought about collectible
card games
also known as ccgs i've never really
played any type of card game before oh
wow okay
yeah so but for somebody who has never
played this type of game
me being one of those like what would
you say like your best advice to them
and like what can they expect
a digital card game like like ours is so
much easier to get into you know you're
not dealing with like collecting a bunch
of cards you have to store physically
and things like that and when we made
this game we assumed
nobody would know how to play so there's
a there's a tutorial you can use there's
a lot of challenges
thank you and congratulations on your
award who gets the award
who gets to keep it are you guys like
passing around so talking guys
just kidding i'll take a lot of photos
with it and then at the end when we can
finally go back i don't know hopefully
early next year we'll
probably have it in our uh in our area
the mac app of the year is fantastical
now
this app is really interesting because
it has been around quite a while but
what they did with this app for this
year specifically
is they had to completely shift around a
lot of their product roadmaps
to kind of fit the way that we're
working now so i got a chance to chat
with michael who showed me some really
cool features of fantastic how
how's everything going congrats it's a
whirlwind i have to show you this this
is
just incredible i am i am speechless it
looks
so cool how is it heavy it weighs like
i'm not kidding it's probably like 20
pounds
ah it's so cool it's like a extended
mac mini wow the m1s really are heavy
duty so you see this join button that's
here
so this is really magical so what it's
doing is when you have a meeting that
you've created and you have a zoom link
or a google meet link
or a skype link or you name it link
literally we want to support every
service and we pretty much do
it will automatically scan the event for
the link and automatically put a join
button in your list
so you never again have to be like
where's that link that's so cool because
it is such a hassle
um the other cool thing that we did was
adding the ability to create conference
calls when you create your meetings
tomorrow
1pm i click add zoom meeting and just
like that here's all my zoom options
with this one creation point i'm
creating the event
i'm inviting you i'm adding the zoom
meeting and you're getting the zoom
invite all with one click
all these updates that you guys did is
is really incredible you guys are saving
2020 for all of us clicking those zoom
and webex links and everything
the mac game of the year is disco
elysium apple tv app of the year is
disney plus
i'm a disney plus subscriber has anybody
watched the second season of mandalorian
yet because i have not so please
no spoilers i can't wait to watch it i
love the first season so much the apple
tv game of the year is dandara trials of
fear actually haven't played this one
either but it is now on my two playlist
it's kind of cool because there are some
apps and games on this list that i never
got a chance to try
and i mean what better time than now
they've already been certified as the
top apps of 2020.
what are we waiting for this one is kind
of neat this is the apple watch of the
year it's called endl i've also never
tried this
and me being such a huge apple watch fan
also
on the to try list the apple arcade game
of the year
is without a doubt one of my favorite
games so this is incredibly fitting that
it did win
half of the year sneaky sasquatch but
this game is so cute and it's incredible
and i know you guys have heard me talk
about it before and
my sister has also said this is her
favorite game and you guys also know
that i kind of love bigfoot too so it is
the perfect game ever if you haven't
checked it out definitely recommend so
now we're going into the app trends of
the year which as a reminder was
helpfulness
so the first one is shine and this is
for helping users practice self-care and
the next one is explain
everything i already talked about this
one at the beginning that's the
whiteboard app that you can do remote
collaboration the next one is caribou
and this is used for connecting families
to loved ones
the next one is pokemon go the amount of
pokemon go that i played when this game
first came out
what this game did for me is it kind of
became like this lifestyle like i would
actually
plan out times during the day where i
would go play pokemon go
i found so many really cool restaurants
so many amazing parks
i met so many of you guys out in the
middle of the street
and when you see somebody walking around
with their phone in their face you have
that connection
it's like we know what you're doing
you're playing pokemon go had i shown
you this like you know a year and a half
ago it'd be like oh yeah i guess that's
normal
um nowadays you look at that and you're
like i hope that's not by my house i
hope no one i know is in there
we tried to make it so regardless of
your situation and still be able to play
the essence of pokemon
go and actually today we are launching
our new
go beyond update which is our biggest
update ever to pokemon go it includes
pokemon that are new to the game
originally from the kalos region
new seasons new ways to enjoy events in
our game like pokemon go fest
and updates to leveling for every single
player and the last one is
share the meal and this is cool because
you can basically share a meal with a
child in need so you basically only need
80 cents and that will feed
one child for a day i'm on their website
right now and it says that they've
shared
over 89 000 meals
that's pretty impressive there's also
the most downloaded charts which this is
kind of interesting so the top free
iphone apps
zoom tick tock disney plus youtube
instagram
facebook snapchat messenger gmail and
the cash app if you guys had to pick
your top favorite apps
of 2020 leave in the comments below what
would they be
top paid iphone apps touch retouch
procreate pocket dark sky weather
face tune hot schedules auto sleep track
sleep the wonder weeks
sky view shadow rocket and sky guide top
free iphone games among us call of duty
mobile
roblox subway surfers ink ink tattoo
drawing
oh i'm interested magic tiles 3 the
piano game freaking loved magic tiles
brain test
tricky puzzles brain out coin master and
cube surfer
top paid iphone games minecraft plague
inc heads up monopoly balloons td6
geometry dash
nba 2k20 grand theft auto the game of
life
and true skate there are so many games
that i have not played top free ipad
apps we've got
zoom disney plus youtube netflix google
chrome
tiktok amazon prime video gmail hulu
and google classroom the top paid ipad
apps are procreate good notes 5
notability duet display teach your
monster lumafusion
yeah freaking love lumafusion affinity
designer
toca hair salon 3 toca life hospital
toga kitchen i've never heard of those
but i'm interested top free ipad games
among us
roblox magic tiles 3 inc inc
call of duty mobile subway surfers
dancing road color ball run
tiles hop edm rush mario kart tour
yes save the girl exclamation point
top paid ipad games minecraft monopoly
balloons td6
plague ink geometry dash the game of
life five nights at freddy's
human fall flat stardew valley and
terraria
top arcade games sneaky sasquatch hot
lava
skate city sonic racing pac-man party
royale
spongebob party pursuit ocean horn 2
crossy road castle what the golf and
lego brawls
wow wow that's a lot of apps what are my
top favorite apps
i left my phone downstairs you would
think that i would have my phone with me
at this current point in time
i guess my top five most used apps
i would say is instagram twitter
messages i'm always in the messaging app
and then as far as like conferencing
goes
i use zoom i use webex and i also use
microsoft teams a lot one app that i
just recently started using a lot for my
live streams is epocam
a pocket i might be mispronouncing it
you can use
your iphone as a webcam so you can
either use it on wi-fi
or you can plug it into your computer
and it'll basically turn your iphone
into a webcam i actually used it for a
couple of my live streams before and i
don't
think anybody even noticed or thought
wow that's an iphone that she's using
it looks so good i definitely recommend
it it's new by elgato they make all
kinds of really cool gaming stuff so
that's one app that was kind of
a big surprise for me and i've been
using it quite a lot so i guess that's
it i just wanted to share with you guys
this really cool apple news
i feel like for a lot of us apps have
kind of kept us entertained
kept us sane and kept us more connected
than ever be sure to subscribe and i
will see you in the next video bye